this idea of rituals is kind of
interesting
again you mentioned cult
what's the role of ritual consumption of
some of these substances or just ritual
practice of anything in
the intellectual growth of
particular groups of people or societies
so again i would say it is the the
centerpiece of ancient life not just the
mysteries of dionysus uh which we've
only talked a bit about but the
mysteries of ellucis were probably the
most famous
and longest lasting of these greek
mystery rites and i mean just to put it
in simple terms the best definition for
a mystery religion
as the name implies is something secret
all right muo from the greek means to
shut the eyes or or to shut the mouth up
to keep quiet about this stuff um you
know we're always teasing details
from the archaeological and the literary
record and we're kind of just
grabbing at these at these secrets but
ellucis which survives for like 2000
years into the christian period from
about 1500 bc to the 4th century a.d
it's kind of this this centerpiece of
greek life cicero the great roman
statesman calls what was happening at
ellusis
the most exceptional and divine thing
that athens ever produced so not
democracy the arts and sciences or
philosophy but
the vision
that was encountered atalusis perhaps
through the ritual consumption of a
potent psychedelic over hundreds and
hundreds of years thousands and
thousands if not millions of initiates
pilgrims who would walk from athens to
ellucis to encounter this vision it
seems to have been
not just an important part of greek life
but the thing that made life livable
such that as these mysteries are about
to be exterminated by the newly
christianized roman empire there's this
passage in the ancient literature that
talks about these you know in the
absence of these mysteries life becomes
unlivable
is there ways you can i mean you write
about the mysteries of ulysses and is
there ways you can convert that into
words
why those are so important
to them
more important than any other invention
to them why is it such a source of
meaning to life
so from what we can reconstruct
they would make that pilgrimage 13 miles
northwest of athens to confront their
mortality remember we were talking about
homo naledi and in south africa this
recognition of self-mortality um the
deliberate disposal of the dead um plato
talks about the the real practice of
philosophy being the the death and dying
process so
in in some senses you went to elusive to
die
and to experience a a death before your
death we talked about this with with
terence mckenna as well and this the how
the psychedelic state
seems to share something in common with
the near-death or out-of-body
experiences or these ecstatic
experiences whether through wine or beer
or otherwise you went to ellucis to die
and it was said that only those who had
witnessed this vision whatever vision
was to be witnessed in demeter sanctuary
it essentially vouched safe to
the afterlife that only those who went
there became immortal
and cicero says that um you know at that
point you essentially live
with more joy and die with a better hope
you